[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb cash is
King in the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth the work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsey personality host
of the smart money happy hour co-host
with Rachel Cruz is my co-host today
here on the Ramsey Show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money Liz starts off this
hour in Charlotte North Carolina hi Liz
how are you I'm good Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call so I am based
in North Carolina
um and I make 43 000 a year I'm on baby
step two paying off debt I just cut up
my first credit card which was a
whirlwind
um but got through that and now I have
twenty thousand dollars in debt and
student loans to the government and I
had two questions kind of involving that
one should I wait to pay it off for like
wait for it to get forgiven or should I
start paying it off now and the second
one kind of comes in with that my dad
passed a few years ago and left an
inheritance I have literally the exact
change amount to pay that off
um I've been hesitant to do that because
I kind of want to feel my own pain of my
own stupid decision but I also don't
want to put that money towards my loans
I'd rather do something more important
with it
um so yeah that's my kind of question
cool
is that your only debt twenty thousand
dollars for student loans yes I thought
you said you cut up a credit card no
doubt on it yes yeah no I always paid
off my my limit but George Kim will help
me figure out okay let me I need to cut
it up I did look at that who knew Dave
that's awesome to hear Liz so if this is
the only debt and you said The
Inheritance is to the penny the amount
now I don't know what your faith
background is you know you can call it a
coincidence but that just seems pretty
happenstance
that the inheritance matches up to your
debt
it is and I I've thought a lot about it
and it just and my dad was very like
very financially
um I mean he came in he came over from
Venezuela and he
um had a very difficult life providing
for himself in the family so he was on
track like trying to do he didn't agree
with Dave all together but I started on
the Dave train a little while ago but
um he really wanted me to own a home and
really wanted me to get like financially
um supported supporting myself so I just
I don't know if I'm crazy for using that
money or if I'm like I I also don't want
to not feel the pain of my own decision
yeah
um
uh
um
your dad I'm gonna guess
was a person of great integrity
yes
yeah he was and so you paying off a loan
that you signed your name to and
borrowed
even if it later might be paid off by
the government is an act of integrity
that I think he would be proud of
[Music]
yeah yeah I know
and I think if you use your inheritance
for that I don't think he would call you
stupid and neither would I
um and I don't think you have to get 30
lashes on your back just to prove that
you learned a lesson
I I think you've learned your lesson I
hope you've learned your lesson are you
going to go borrow money again
no no no okay if you're through then
you're through right and so you know
let's use this and get cleaned up and
then build your emergency fund and then
let's start Building Wealth so that you
can leave it uh to your heirs and have
the same kind of Legacy that your dad
had
no yeah yeah I I I was at dinner with my
family the other night and I told them
this plan of hanging off and they all
looked at me like I was crazy and they
they ripped me to shreds and I said no
but this is about integrity so I I thank
you for your advice yeah yeah I I just I
think one of the things I always think
about when someone asked me
um what they should do with an
inheritance that they got is always
think about the person that left the
inheritance and what would make them
smile from heaven
and I don't think you paying off your
debts now that you've learned your
lesson and you living a financially
responsible life going forward
regardless of if some half-butt family
member ripped you to shreds or not
um
you know uh I just you know I'm just
going to pay off a debt that I actually
owe
and not wait on uh welfare and
um I I gotta feel in your dad's smiling
about that
um and so uh and here's the other thing
five years from today
if you live forward following the Ramsey
process continuing in the baby steps
you're going to have substantial money
and five years from today are you going
to look back if the debts are forgiven
by uh the government later are you going
to look back and feel like you did
something wrong no you're not
so you're not going to have regret long
term from having done the right thing
even if it even if it has a little bit
of pain to it and even if stupid people
disagree with you stupid people disagree
with you all the time when it comes to
money that's why we call them stupid
people they don't get a vote you're not
taking a poll and so you raised the
question earlier Liz of what if there's
more important things I should be doing
with this money and I can think of
nothing more important than setting
yourself free financially from this debt
that's been hanging over your neck and
if they forgive if the bind
Administration gets it through the
courts and next week they come out and
forgive it which they're not going to
but I I personally wouldn't have any
regret because I signed up for this trip
and I took the trip you know this this
decision is taking up too much mental
space when it could be free right now
too many calories
Brooke is in Hattiesburg Mississippi hi
Brooke what's up
hey Dave hey George how are you guys
better than we deserve how can we help
so this is a money question but it's
mostly an emotional psychological
question I think
um my husband and I want your advice on
whether or not we should go home to
visit family for Christmas this year uh
the back story for that is that we live
here in Mississippi and both of our
families live in the North and every
year it's our routine to stop in Ohio go
to New York and come back because we're
the only ones that live in the south my
husband is getting his PhD in genetics
at USM
I'm super proud of him about that so uh
and we have the only grandchild
on both sides of the family uh so
everyone very much wants to see us yeah
you have a great you have great bait
come see us if you want to see the
grandchild Mississippi
the Mississippi Christmas oh yeah and
she's she's the sweetest too I love her
but anyway
um so we've been working our baby steps
and it has been
a bit of an uphill battle with you know
with my husband still in his um PhD
program and I'm trying as best as I can
to be a stay-at-home mom and uh still
bring in uh the income that we need to
do everything we need to do but we've uh
paid off probably close to twenty
thousand dollars in debt and the last
that we are uh that we have left is
about five thousand dollars left on a
credit card I would choose to spend this
Christmas in Mississippi and invite
everyone to come see you and if they
don't want to go that was their choice
and you guys are gonna have a great
little Christmas one year one year and
they can they're more than welcome we'd
love to have them nobody's mad at
anybody we just can't do it this year
I'm so sorry
um you know by the way when you go
through your life it changes as to who
visits who with the the different phases
of your life this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
Hey procrastiniters listen up we're
extending our Cyber Monday sale where
you can get our best prices of the year
on your favorite products for this week
only you can get our best-selling books
and tools as low as five dollars
apparently our marketing department did
not get the inflation memo because we
have a deflation recession thing going
on at ramseysolutions.com everything's
down
that just makes no sense but it is
that's what well I mean we're trying to
help people kidding us I don't try to
sell stuff so you can shop our quick
reads like my latest quick read which is
called the momentum theorem or Dr John
deloney's redefining anxiety all of
those are under ten dollars most of the
number one best sellers are ten dollars
the best selling bundle we have the
starter special is 77 off it's got the
stuff in it you need to start working on
all this and of course the baby steps
millionaires my latest number one is
only ten dollars
most of our books are ten dollars so
that's ten bucks for 100 bucks you
really cannot beat this stuff this is a
season to share hope with other people
this is a way to do it it's not
condemning to give them a book on how to
get their act together you just say hey
this helped me I hope it'll help you
that's all you have to do instead of
like you know here's a book on losing
weight because you're fat don't do that
don't do that that's not good Cyber
Monday sale uh continues all week long
at ramsesolutions.com remember prices as
low as five dollars so George
they're dropping like flies who is the
um
the Bitcoin boys oh my goodness the
Bitcoin the Bitcoin Bros are they're
just they're just dying like on the vine
I don't know what's happening they're
like the dinosaurs they're gonna look
back it's almost like um
like they had a bad business model
wait you mean you mean like money fake
money didn't work or something you know
I'm gloating a little because I caught
so much hell from you Bitcoin Bros for
the last three years five years on how
stupid a boomer I am and how out of
touch I am well I'm telling you to stay
away from this crap and now another one
files bankruptcy just a few minutes ago
right oh yeah yeah we had block five
block fi crypto lender block five
follows FTX into bankruptcy and follows
uh four others so they'll filed this
week into bankruptcy it's because it was
a house of cards
Zay is dropping like flies man
it's not it's not it's uh I doubt many
of our listeners had their money tied up
in this kind of crap because they
actually listened to this show so I hope
no one out there listening was hurt by
this situation because users are going
to their accounts and it's zero and
they're not getting their money back in
these situations so it's it's a scary
environment if you did throw a bunch of
money into crypto which millions of
people have you remember the old uh
movie It's a Wonderful Life oh yeah
it'll run on the bank yeah you go to get
get your money out and you can't get it
out the bank went broke who knew It's a
Wonderful Life it's it's a modern day
tale I wonder if there's any little
angels with their bells ringing on this
one I'm guessing not I'm guessing
there's some devils doing the dance with
their pitchforks instead uh you gotta
wonder how many more kind of thinking
there's not any dangers involved in this
now could be wrong I mean the guy looks
like Belushi in Animal House
so there's no way that he's a
oh actually belushian Animal House as
stoned as he was looks better than this
guy so
um wow that's what happens you don't get
out of the basement often enough for
from fresh air and a haircut
oh man this is a house of cards Dave
truthfully I mean the whole thing is
just crumbling because they were all
intertwined with each other and it turns
out uh it was only worth what people
were willing to pay for it based on hype
instead of based on actual you know
revenues and profits which is what the S
P 500 is based off of well and to recoup
I mean we're gloating and carrying on
and poking fun at you people but we gave
you great intellectual and academic
detail on why this was going to happen
I just truthfully did not think it would
happen at this scale this soon
even that caught me by surprise I
figured it was gonna you know it would
unravel there'd be a few things drop
here or there and eventually the thing
would stabilize and you know over a
period of a decade began to get some
actual credibility I thought it would
probably work its way through I don't
know if the whole thing makes it it may
it may just come completely cave in I
mean the domino effect on this is
because I mean well because here's the
thing Rabbi this is an interesting
lesson for everybody not just Bitcoin
but about everything Rabbi Lapin talks
about this book our our good friend he's
an Orthodox Jewish rabbi best-selling
book called thou shall prosper in the
book he looks at money for through the
Jewish lens and he explains to us
properly that money
is not about math money is about trust
money is spiritual
and so that's why all kinds of weird
things have been used as a medium of
exchange throughout history whether it
be a gold bar
Wampum that we trade Long Island for
Furs in the Old West Pioneer Days you
know two beaver pelts why would you take
a a skinned beaver pelt as payment for
something because you trust you believe
that other people will exchange that for
uh some biscuit dough and some hard tack
right and so you know that you know you
can use anything as a medium of exchange
if you trust that it can be used to
exchange goods in the Old Testament uh
one of the things that was used was oil
oil was used to keep the holy of holies
the lamps burning in the temple in the
holy of holies and oil was a symbol of
God's spirit was used to anoint Kings
you see the prophets pouring oil over
the top of the head of King David or
King Saul anointing them King and and
oil because it was prized then you could
literally go into the marketplace in
those days with a carafe of oil and do
an exchange and so when the Bible says
in the house of the wise are stores of
choice food and oil it's an indication
of wealth Choice food and oil were
indications of wealth because it was
used for a medium of exchange you can
use
I don't know textiles you could use
anything that's another person would
accept and so it's about trust it's a
spiritual thing money is spiritual and
all money is spiritual uh the dollar
bills no exception it's not magical the
only reason the dollar bill is
um more is more believable has more
credibility is because it's more widely
accepted and has a longer track record
that's all yeah and you know backed by
the government and so that that's where
the regulation comes in versus uh yeah
but you have to believe that that
matters we all are in agreement that
this dollar is worth something I I just
I'm really the backing of the government
doesn't even impress me anymore it's
just the idea that I know that I can
take this and go buy a stake with it I
can fill up my car with it well I can't
I can put a few dollars I've put a
little bit of stuff in my car but a
little bit of gas in my car but you know
what I'm saying it's uh and crypto never
really had that it doesn't have a track
record it wasn't volatile it was too
volatile it was too narrowly accepted by
a very narrow portion of the population
and yet everyone attributed to it the
same
credibility the same spiritual power
that say the dollar or even the peso or
even the Yen has and it's not it was not
there yeah it was a Nuance within the
economy even though it was massive it
was still a Nuance within the world
economy it had not yet proven itself no
it was a a an out of control overgrown
baby child and now it's fallen and
everybody started treating it like it
was a legitimate thing and they got
their heads taken off I kept telling you
don't do that and the fraudsters and the
scammers started to realize we can make
a quick Buck by entering the space well
you know why they entered their space I
mean that's also spiritual because who
was playing in the space were people
looking for quick easy money and people
are looking for quick easy money are
always easy prey to the con artist
and the scammer and so you're most
easily conned when you're afraid or when
you're a greedy
and um if you're neither of those it's
very hard to con you yeah you're not and
you don't you don't fall for it but get
rich quick man if you're in there going
I got I'm cutting edge I'm I'm a Bitcoin
bro man I'm I'm the smartest guy on the
planet and I'm on Tick Tock and that
that proves it right there and I'm all
of this crap and you're setting yourself
up absolutely well I just hope my next
paycheck isn't in Beaver pills I'm a
little worried now Dave of what you're
trying to get at here he's trying to go
back to the old times hmm let's see if
he'll take some textiles this month
oh man George I'm gonna leave at the
break and go hunting that would not
Shock me honestly I'm never killed a
beaver that's why you bought this
property by the woods Dave so you can
take a quick break I can go down there
make a beaver pill and pay George oh
that's what we'll do just go Um get you
know go down there to this segment I'm
gonna be Davy Crockett with this on my
head Dave it's gonna be great he did not
wear a beaver pelt George you were that
was a [ __ ] skin cap you were so lame
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Sandy is with us in Cincinnati hi Sandy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so I am excited to get started
Health
um but my concern is that I am in the
middle of changing homes a lot my my
life is turned upside down and so
um I'm getting divorced how do you start
a budget when you don't even know what
the bills are going to be you know like
I'm going to be moving in three months I
just I'm not sure how to even get
started because right now I have joint
bank accounts and then it's going to
change to be mine so I'm just curious as
to any tips you have about that
horrible time of year to be going
through all that I'm sorry
the divorces
been filed as final as what
it should be final in the next two or
three months so and we've already worked
out most of the details with arbitration
okay then you should be able to close
your joint accounts today
already you should be able to if you if
you're in agreement on it
probably in a month
yeah um so do not put any more money
into
a joint account your attorney should
have told you that
uh well I think my husband is keeping
the house that we're in and I'm moving
out and I think it was just because
that's what we've always been doing and
I guess no but you're not married
anymore soon
and um what we've run into in 30 years
of doing what I do is that sometimes
people get right to this point and it
suddenly is not amicable and suddenly he
takes all the money out of the account
and now you're really screwed so you
need to be able to manage December
and you don't have any money
I do I have a
house that's what I'm saying okay that's
what I said to do all right sorry good
but most of our money is in the joint
account okay but we need we need to we
need to bring the the cash
portion of this agreement to an end as
soon as possible and disperse so that
you can begin to set up that part now
here's the thing you can do a budget
this month
for this month
it'll never be like this again but for
this month you can say for December what
are my expenses and where's my income
and where's my cash going to go and then
for January I gotta move or I got to get
a different place or I got a deposit
it's going to be a different budget
right
okay and then February will be a
different budget but it always is
different you never do the same budget
every month some of them are more
similar than yours are going to be for
the next few months you're going to be
vastly different every month for a while
until it stabilizes but you have to tell
your money this month what to do before
it leaves because you're in the middle
of
um a hugely volatile crisis situation
and it will give you great peace if you
take control of this one area of your
life
okay well we pay all of our bills though
from the joint account and it's like
automatic so I like out of my personal
account I'm not paying any okay so what
is your budget for this month okay given
that the this weird joint account
situation that's in limbo is going to
take care of our bills but you still
have some things you have to do in
December as a newly independent person
right
and you need to write out that budget
there's probably not a lot to it is what
you're saying okay and uh but you need a
game plan all right and it might be that
I'm setting aside a pile of money
because in January after Christmas I got
to move out and I can need deposits
right
right I'm gonna actually buy my house in
cash wow
yeah I have an inheritance so
um I'm I'm gonna do that and are you
renting in between are you jumping right
into the home purchase
jumping right in
um it's yeah it's crazy but
um I don't want to loan money at a high
interest rate and I've got the money and
the inheritance and I'm buying a
reasonable house you know like 260 000
um how much is in your inheritance
um my portion will probably be about 300
plus you don't have the money yet
I do
you said you're you if you don't if you
have the money you should know how much
it is
probably be well because I'm going to
get
[Music]
so it's much larger so it's all your
portion
and you have that already
yes okay so it's not probably be it's up
to you and so how much is your
inheritance that is in your account
[Music]
okay cool and so yeah because that
matters I mean if you got 200 262 000
and you're going to spend 260. that's a
little less reasonable oh yeah yeah well
you know the other thing is that I'm not
settling the estate it's all mine it's
nearly settled until after the divorce
that way there's absolutely no way that
he can get it
told me to do so like we have all the
papers ready to go but so you don't have
the 450.
I could settle the estate today if I
wanted to
but I'm choosing to wait until after the
divorce so that there's it's cleaner but
it's all in accounts and it's there's no
one else I got you okay
well the question was about starting the
budget starting this process and
budgeting is a habit and so you're it's
going to take you know on average it
takes 90 days to get a hang of this
budget and now is the best time to start
when you're in the situation you need to
be paying attention to where every
single dollar is going and protect it
because this marriage has become a
financial transaction and you need to
now stay protected yeah and let's get
the things unraveled as quickly as
possible
um
you're not gonna do this
but my advice to you would be to not buy
a house right now
uh you're hell-bent on doing this but
Sandy just in talking to you you're
chasing your tail through the whole
conversation I mean one minute it's one
thing one minute another thing we'll
miss another thing you don't you know
you're discombobulated all over the
place and you don't need to be buying a
house when your head's in the space it's
in right now uh and it's normal
transaction for us as we tell people
after you go through in the middle of a
major crisis where you're grieving
something like this I don't care if it's
a relief it's still a divorce it's still
one of the 10 things that'll put you in
the hospital it's still high stress high
anxiety situation unbelievable levels of
emotion and cortisol coursing through
your body and it affects your ability to
make decisions and just the conversation
with you is discombobulated and so I'm
just telling you if you're my little
sister I would love you and tell you not
to buy a house right now let's go rent
something for six months and let the
emotional dust settle you will make
different decisions and by the way don't
commit to giving any of this inheritance
away for six months let the emotional
dust settle
um there's all all kinds of psychology
behind you're about to make mistakes
here
and but you're going to do whatever
because I can tell we're not going to
stop you but the way you do a budget is
you do it for that month
with what you have to work with and then
you do it for the next month with what
you have to work with and so you don't
have to wait until everything stabilizes
to start doing a budget as a matter of
fact the only way it will stabilize is
to do a budget this month and then do a
budget next month and then do a budget
next month and then you're stabilizing
what you can yeah they're not static
it's you know December has Christmas and
so that affects your budget for that
month and January is going to have its
own expenses and so you've got to be
restarting this process a lot of the
line items will stay the same but it
will fluctuate especially if you have a
regular income slowing down
on large giving decisions to relatives
that were not in the will slowing down
on large purchase decisions like a home
in the middle of this much upheaval and
volatility in your life is not fear it
is not weakness it is wisdom
so what we are recommending here is
wisdom we're not calling you weak or
inept we're saying you just got T-boned
and you're kind of Dazed and you're
walking around the intersection with
with little birds flying around your
head in a cartoon and you need to get
where you can sit down the curb for a
minute let your head clear before you
start admitting fault in this accident
that's what the kind of crap we're
dealing with here it's trauma this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
we have now proven in a culture that has
completely
soft coddled raised by helicopter
parents enabled
that you can be offended by almost
anything because you people are so
wisified out there I never dreamed
George that you would actually post an
Instagram about eating at home is
cheaper than eating out and you would
piss off half of the nation you know how
in the world is that controversial you
started the trend Dave because you've
always said I know but how is it how is
it that America is so completely
lucified that the idea that you should
not eat out if you're broke causes you
to be angry and hate George
unbelievable in their defense I have a
punchable face I understand no but not
for that you might get a punchable face
for something else that's what happens
this is just pit
I do enjoy eating out even though I'm
poor you need to value your own time as
if you're a king it takes time to make
your own food you wussies you
unbelievable little children people
unbelievable I love I would watch an
entire show of Just Dave doing
impressions of the commenters this is
brilliant okay I don't even read
comments but they told me they were
vicious on your Instagram so I pulled
them up and I am laughing my butt off at
how pitiful you people are commenting on
this you are absolute morons this is
unbelievable here's what happened Dave
we our social team took a 10 second clip
from my talk at our smart conference
event in Dallas about the cost of eating
out and we're trying to help people find
margin in their budgets with inflation
so I'm just telling people hey eat at
home eat a new place called Mikasa and
if you want to save some money so James
play the clip so that everyone
understands why you were the most hated
man in America who knew this is how I
get canceled
the average cost of a meal right now is
13 bucks eating at home four bucks so
when you eat out here's the math because
I'm a nerd you spent 325 percent more
enjoy that that was the entire clip and
uh it got 1.7 million views on Tick Tock
300 000 views on Instagram and most of
those were like hate watches because
they're angry and I will say Dave there
was one comment that was true it is 225
more it's 3.25 times more but 225
percent more so for the true nerds in
the comments I salute your extra math
there but for everyone else they're
going what was this the 1990s you can
eat out for my Taco Bell cost 16 dollars
guys let me just tell you it's a simple
freaking formula if you run a restaurant
you pay the food cost
and you pay rent and you pay insurance
and you pay labor to cook the food
hypothetically and deliver it to one of
you people who have no idea that you can
actually cook at home apparently it was
shocking to your little systems that you
might actually engage in labor in your
own freaking kitchen other than your
crop unbelievable man my favorite is
people saying well Dave I saved so much
time when I go to Red have you been to a
restaurant you got to drive there number
one well here's the thing oh and I left
out profit yep and tip and tip well
these people don't tell clearly clearly
oh no this is unbelievable so here's the
thing I don't mind you eating at a
restaurant George doesn't mind you
eating in a restaurant but to say that
it is punishment
against your little soul that you
shouldn't eat at a restaurant when
you're freaking broke is so lucified
people that's ridiculous and of course
it's cheaper to cook at home of course
it's cheaper now I don't know if it's 13
versus four dollars or a hundred and
thirty dollars versus 50 bucks but a
hundred percent of you that can do any
level of math have to know that it is
cheaper to make the exact same meal at
home than it is at any restaurant you
are paying for the entertainment value
and the convenience of eating out those
things are called luxuries wimp that's
right and regardless of the numbers like
you mentioned Dave it's about the ratios
and no matter where you look online and
what numbers you pull up eating out is
going to cost three four five x what it
costs sure it does now here's the thing
these people don't understand Dave when
I said it's four dollars a meal I'm not
saying the meal for the entire family
was four dollars I'm talking about it
doesn't matter George they were arguing
the only reason they want pick apart
your math is because they didn't like
your conclusion that their little butt
should eat at home when they're poor you
know it is listen I've been poor and you
know
you know we ate at home we were poor we
were broke poor is a mindset that's
right broke as I'm passing through okay
but if you're broke you eat at home
yeah you eat at home
and you eat the same thing again
dovers ooh gross I can't stand leftovers
me and Sharon Ramsay agree that we're
big fans of leftovers oh sure she won't
quit wears me out with leftovers to this
day because she remembers being broke
this is not going to waste and there's
stuff in our refrigerator is 83 years
old I mean it's got a mighty and we can
afford to eat out okay going to a nice
steakhouse tonight thank you Jesus all
right and I want you to go out to eat
I'm a big fan of restaurants I like
restaurant people I like eating out but
it is entertainment
and convenience it is not economic a
necessity for survival ever you never
eat out based on economics ever and it
is not an entitlement you wimp
I and my time I may treat myself like a
king oh kiss my butt that is the dumbest
thing I ever heard in my life treatment
say you sound like you're four years old
I mean what is your your emotional
maturity level no age limit for
Instagram Dave could be foreign
what kind of crap is that
kick you while you know what we're
trying to do is keep you from staying
down because you keep making stupid butt
decisions and that's offensive Dave it's
offensive to do be mature it's offensive
to actually have a longer mentality on
things oh it's like God I keep I keep
looking at these they just make me
madder and matter and matter the hour I
spent cooking is sometimes worth the
cost difference
it is
if you can afford it
it's no one disputes that the problem is
people are saying Dave I'm living Beauty
and me going out to eat tonight is
Sharon don't get any leftovers to add to
the refrigerator she might take some
added benefit but that's not an economic
thing that's they don't want any more
leftovers thing okay that's all that is
you know oh my God this can't be current
we've done the math as well oh you idiot
of course it's current it depends on
which meal set you're looking at and
what you actually bought and where you
bought if you're buying organic eggs
from a house chicken at stinking that
was you know it's not even a real
chicken and you're buying it at whole
whole paycheck at Whole Foods instead of
going down the regular grocery store and
getting regular cheap eggs you know you
could pay 18 for a dadgum thing of eggs
or you can pay a whole lot less for a
thing of eggs I mean dozen eggs this is
nuts it's insane and so yes where you
shop matters we talked about that in the
talk at smart conference go shop at Aldi
and buy it in bulk at Costco and you can
save big per serving and people are
saying you can't get out of the
therefore yes you might spend 200 bucks
at Costco but hopefully that feeds you
for two weeks if you want to rationalize
and justify anything you can that's fine
but there's no possible thing you come
off as as except inept and immature when
you start saying that a eating out is
your right
and it's your life in the Constitution
your life is damaged kick us while we're
down oh my God yeah I'll kick you while
you're down don't go on vacation if
you're broke people don't do it I made a
woman on the Today show that I was
coaching cry on National Television
because she went on vacation in the
middle of me coaching her and I'm like
that's the dumbest dadgum thing I've
ever heard if you lost your mind I told
you not to do that and she starts crying
and I got trashed because I jumped her
case about dead gun being stupid here's
the next one you're gonna get Dave Dave
going on vacation is cheaper than my
rent so I'm just gonna go on vacation
it's cheaper
let's make some bad as much sense as
this stupid argument does
yeah and it's and by God it's my right
you can't just work all the time of
course you have to take time off you
work all the time when you're broke
that's what you do it's how you not be
broke anymore my grandmother used to say
there's a great place to go when you're
broke to work
you work that's how you fix that's how
you fix a broke problem it's money comes
from work you work that's what you do is
it a way of life throughout your whole
life no but you little wussy you go to
work that's how you fix this you don't
go out to eat and you don't go on
vacation you're broke it's not a human
right
if you read comments on anything you
know why some species kill their young I
mean it's unbelievable wow this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love to create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell with Ramsey personality the
most hated man in the restaurant
industry is my co-host today it's an
honor uh that and uh and by the horse
people too you oh gosh I forgot about
that actual contingencies of people that
hate you it's awesome I'm so glad that
you're moving things around and causing
some friction it's good to have you here
today yeah so if you don't know he
posted a thing on Instagram that is
cheaper to eat at home than it is
cooking your own food than it is to eat
out and apparently this is a revelation
into people in America so we've had a
lot of fun making fun of you people that
have argued with George common sense is
offensive these days it's so rare it's
like having a superpower Abigail's with
us Abigail's in Nashville hi Abigail
welcome to the Ramsay show hi Dave hi
George it's good to talk to you yeah you
too what's up
um so my husband and I are on baby step
number six and we're curious if we
should use our savings to pay off our
house either now or in the near future
why would you know
well um that is maybe step six
yes no my um we've been unemployed since
September my husband just accepted a job
and we'll start next week yay yeah at a
lower income as we had before but then
I'm also eight months eight months
pregnant phenomenal so I assume when you
say you're taking it out of savings you
still have an emergency fund after you
pay off your house right
um I think so so we we have about 175
saves right now in various money markets
mutual funds stocks all this stuff
um and we owe 148 000. so that would be
like 50 000 bucks left oh 25 000 bucks
left over right so
what's your household
good job it would be 40 000 a year oh
yeah pay off your house tomorrow
really
I mean
well baby what if well the baby's not
gonna affect I mean babies don't cost
foreclosures
no well that's true you have health
insurance and you have your emergency
fund you have twenty five thousand
dollars you have health insurance your
husband has a job and you have a paid
for house I can't think of a better
thing for a baby to come home to
okay what's your mortgage payment
um so our mortgage right now is about
thirteen hundred yeah under what
circumstances do you need a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for your baby
no we don't but um part of that was the
severance package no but under what
circumstances would you need a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars due to the
fact you're having a baby next month
we wouldn't need that much I can't think
of one that's what I'm saying
right so but and you said you said yeah
but baby do I wait after the baby comes
well no I done anything to do with it
and you've increased your cash flow next
month because you don't have principal
and interest to pay
that's true so we're just under our
current insurance plan I think we have
like 17 000 in our deductible so if the
baby had a nicuse say we'd still need
quite a bit of cash but that's just like
the worst case scenario well it's not
the end of the world to wait
um until after baby comes if you want to
but the point being that um
you know I I don't want you sitting
around figuring out a way to rationalize
it you keep this money because it makes
you feel safe because paying off a home
was going to make you feel safer
and by the way if you hate being debt
free you can always go get a mortgage
layer
I think so yeah yeah okay so I mean if
you want to win this baby do
um January okay any indications if
there's any issues
no good good well congratulations that's
wonderful exciting time yeah so what
we're talking about here is the
difference in four weeks or five weeks
oh yeah it's not that long pay off your
house or now or pay it off if the baby
comes I don't care at the end of the
world but what I what I do want to
challenge and what I was doing is to
just challenge your critical thinking on
it because what happens is
um most people me included because
babies are so cool
um and they scare you uh when they come
because it's a whole new set of
responsibilities even if it's the second
or third one it's that much more
responsibility and so you know they're
they're looking at you going I just cost
a lot of money you know
so I mean I I you know I've been through
that myself as a as a dad and then as a
Granddad so I get all of that but what
that is is thinking with emotion rather
than actual math
and that so that's why I'm pushing back
is I just want you to think you know
critically thinking there's a one
percent chance that paying off your
house is a problem here and but if on
that one percent if it just makes you
feel better wait until your baby comes
home and then pay off the house but
don't do not get to the end of February
with a mortgage
okay under any circumstances unless
unless baby has serious problems and
you're in like you said some kind of
Nick you stay or something yeah but um
just don't don't don't don't figure out
another reason to Kick the Can down the
road that's emotional and not logical so
there's always a what if out there but
yeah but I mean the other thing is most
of them end better with a paid for house
I mean what if what if he loses the new
job well paid for a house what if what
if what if what if what if they don't
have a mortgage payment next month there
you go Brady's in St Louis hey Brady
what's up
hey guys how you doing great how can we
help
hey so I've got a couple questions for
you all I uh I'm 21 years old and I uh
I'm in college I'm about to graduate
here in May
thank you sir I've actually signed to uh
start a position already so right what's
your degree on me uh it's going to be in
computer science with the concentration
software engineering wonderful well done
yes sir yes sir thank you and I uh I'm
gonna be um working at Boeing in St
Louis as a software engineer so I'm
super excited about that but my I guess
my general question is how can I set
myself up and I'm a fiancee now getting
married into next year in September how
can I set myself up my kids up my fiance
a whole family or we can be successful
month to month and successful for
retirement and live comfortably
what are you gonna be making
uh I'll be at 82 000 starting salary and
I'll have a 8 000 signing bonus in May
and this is kids this is Future Kids
your fiance doesn't already have kids
you don't already have kids exactly okay
thinking ahead so do you have any debt
uh I have uh I have no student loans
graduating but I have about twenty
thousand dollars in car loan
okay well your A1 would be to pay that
off uh when you get out you have any
money saved up
uh I have about two thousand dollars
saved up now yeah okay graduated get
married get the job get that car paid
off that's thing one your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income and
if you quit giving it to other people it
sets you up right
okay yes sir so the best thing you can
do is get out of debt stay out of debt
have a pile of money in the bank be
investing for the future pay off your
house once you get that as soon as you
can and man that is the way to set up
your family's future and you're going to
get there in no time at 21 making the
money you're making it's only going up
from here if you follow the steps the
baby steps we teach you'll be there in
no time I'm gonna gift you Financial
Peace University to help kick start this
journey for you so hang on the line
Austin will pick up we're gonna gift you
that watch all nine lessons with your
fiance as a pre-marital counseling it'll
change everything man I'm telling you
oh every young couple getting married
ought to do that wow this is the Ramsay
show
[Applause]
[Music]
s
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
the holiday season where our brains are
focused on buying presents decorating
our homes and all the Christmas New Year
celebrations and then all of a sudden
January's here and some people hit
January with what's known as a financial
hangover well we have the antidote for
keeping you from doing that and it's
called get signed up for Building Wealth
live we're going to be doing it here in
Nashville January the 12th this one
night event will help you kick off 2023
feeling confident about your finances
Rachel Cruz George Campbell Ken Coleman
me Dr John deloney join us as we walk
you through a simple but proven plan to
get back on track and build wealth yes
it is possible our Building Wealth
events have been a huge hit and we just
wrapped up our sold out fall season a
lot of fun and our January event will be
here in the Ramsey headquarters but
we're also headed to Indianapolis Austin
Salt Lake City and Anaheim all the dates
in the spring they're selling very very
rapidly passes are only 39 to come to
these events Building Wealth live get
your tickets to Nashville today at
ramseysolutions.com slash
events
ramseysolutions.com
events our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you miss measure or you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free free samples free shipping and
new promos all the time you'll save even
more use the promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from Claire in Vermont she asks does
contribution toward teacher pension
count in the 15 investing in retirement
or should 15 percent be invested and
then the pension contribution be extra
on top of that I'm asking for my
mother-in-law who is 63. she started an
IRA outside of the pension but that's
been started pretty recently
all right so a lot of numbers got thrown
around there with pension but what she's
asking is you know if the company is
paying into the pension not the person
how does that affect this uh baby step
four or 15 it doesn't at all if the
company's paying it if you have a
pension that you are required that's
mandatory for you to put money in and
you're putting in 15 there's two
problems uh with that three problems
with that one is you have no control of
it it's not an asset of yours it's an
asset of the company if the company goes
broke the pension goes with it so if uh
you work for XYZ company that just filed
chapter 11 bankruptcy because they were
in the Bitcoin or something then you
would have zero pension because your
pension goes broke when the company goes
broke the second problem with the
pension is um you don't have control
over what's it is invested in and so it
doesn't produce as much income later and
of course the third problem is it dies
when you die so uh you lose it it's gone
poof just like smoke and so all of that
to say if you are putting 15 in it's not
as good as you putting 15 in the other
but we'll count it I would count it
something if I were in your shoes I
maybe half or something like that that's
what we usually say yeah so let's uh for
an example if you have to put in 12 it's
mandatory we would count that at about
six percent half because of the poor
performance because you have no control
so if you have that six you'd still put
another nine to get to 15 baby step four
great question Mary's in Boise Idaho hi
Mary welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
um I have a question about
um gift giving and gift receiving at the
holidays
um my husband and I are we don't have
any debt other than like no credit card
debt no student loan debt um we do have
some automobiles that not home of course
so we're rapidly paying those off and
every year we tell our siblings I have
three siblings my husband has two we
have a total of 11 nieces and nephews
plus our parents we just say no gifts we
just want to see you we just want to
hang out and every year we find out
everybody's getting us gifts and then
last excuse me last minute we all we
decide to buy them something but it
doesn't feel like it's coming from the
heart so I guess my question is is it
cheap of us to know that we're going to
be receiving gifts and not give gifts
because we're focusing on ourselves or
is this the time when we just put our
financial goals aside
so that we can gift people with
something
um
I don't think I I personally don't think
you're cheap I think forced generosity
where I'm I'm giving you something and
I'm expecting something in return that
is not the spirit of giving to begin
with so if you've had that conversation
and they are resentful of you then you
can't carry that that's not on you I
don't feel like there's resentment there
it's guilt on your own bad we're gonna
we're gonna give you something anyway so
then so it's just I guess it's just in
between our ears where we feel like
we're being cheap by not
getting everybody something yeah but I
mean if you do well the maps you can do
whatever you want to do obviously any
family can do whatever they want to do
um our families years ago when Sharon
and I went broke we sat down with all of
her brothers and sisters there's 13
grandkids on that side
um and uh five brothers and sisters and
spouses right so there's 20 something
people involved yeah and going into
Christmas and her folks as an example
all right and we had to sit down with
them and we said guys we're really sorry
um
we cannot afford to buy everybody a gift
and so we're begging you guys to join us
in this it's kind of gotten ridiculous
anyway unless the let the adults draw
names and each one by one a gift and and
little kids that are under whatever 10
or something get gifts and the rest of
them are in the drawing you know or
whatever thing and would you all join us
in this because we don't want to come in
here and feel guilty and if y'all are
all going to give each other gifts and
we're going to be sitting here feeling
guilty we're not going to be able to
come because we don't want to sit here
in that
um okay and you know what they went
thank God somebody said it out loud we
always were thinking the same thing they
weren't even broken they were just glad
to draw names because it gets just dumb
anyway right I mean you're buying
somebody you see something you see four
or five times a year a gift and they've
already bought anything they really
wanted and so it goes in a drawer or
it's thrown away or ends up in the
seldom used kitchen items bin or
whatever it is you know and so it's it's
it starts to be silly really yeah in
most families now some families are
unbelievably into it and whatever that's
fine but uh I would just have a
conversation please don't put us in this
position
and then I guess my next question is
when you get to the step of give wealth
and get uh you know gain wealth and
Giver
um
we're extremely wealthy and our kids the
Ramsey kids got together at Thanksgiving
and true names as a matter of fact
there's an app that you can use to draw
names
okay I found that out at the
Thanksgiving table this year there's an
app for that of course Rachel knows
there's an app for drawing names right
and I think it's more fun anyways that
way and then no one's going well he got
three gifts and I got two in his were
worth more than and it just becomes a
weird Spirit to the whole thing I mean
our kids can afford to give each other
anything they want to give them and we
can afford to give them anything we want
to give them it's ridiculous and we
don't
we don't I mean we we just we give we're
we drew names and we're going to do that
and you know now Mimi's gonna I know our
philosophy is you know just spending
time with each other that's all the
gifts we want even if we were
millionaires it's like I just wanted
that's the point that's the point and so
we do one gift in the spirit of gift
giving
for adults and all the little kids get
gifts and it's fun to watch the little
seven-year-olds get gifts that's fine
that usually doesn't kill you but it's
just the the big thing here is the
manipulation of the relationship process
to where you you ask them not to put you
into this position and you'll probably
find that somebody will go along and you
may have to kind of draw a line and go
you know we're just not going to be able
to be here if you're going to put us in
this position because we just don't
think that way and you know we'll get
with you another time and uh we're not
going to sit here and watch all y'all
open gifts and we didn't buy them that's
just awkward as awkward as crud that's
just weird I don't want to be I don't
want to be guilt-tripped intentionally
or unintentionally or in my own ear
between my own ears or whatever it's a
difficult time you know the beauty
Georgia of this time of year is you get
to see your family the the bad thing is
you get to see your family
both and
I mean our cousins sit around we're
adults now and we just give each other a
25 gift card and I get a 25 gift already
Santa stuff is a lot more fun yes the
gag gifts have fun with it steal from
each other more fun set a gift limit I
think that should be the new trend this
Christmas just tear into it absolutely
you know I mean oh my gosh which by the
way Dave myself to buy you a gift and I
expect one in return
George the chance of me feeling guilty
about this is really close to zero maybe
negative amounts I'm thinking I'm
thinking beaver pelt I think oh gosh
back to the beaver Pelton could we go
make a hat out of it George this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more bursts
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality host
of smart money happy hour at least
co-host with Rachel Cruz is my co-host
here today on the Ramsey Show in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage David and Jessica are with us
hey guys how are you hey Dad welcome
here where do you guys live just outside
of Louisville Kentucky oh cool well
welcome glad to have you in Nashville so
here to do a dead free scream how much
did you pay off about 120 000. all right
how long did that take 22 months good
for you and your range of income during
that two years about 110 to 150. cool
what do you all do for a living I'm a
commercial truck driver and I'm a
supervisor for pharmacy operations
awesome good it and what kind of debt
was this one hundred and twenty thousand
everything everything credit cards
student loans uh cars medical bills
medical bills personal loans all of it
you guys were like normal super normal
super normal and normal socks so how
long you all been married all of the
years the whole time
how long you been married five years
okay and out of the five years about two
years ago something happened and gave
you a wake-up call tell us what happened
and how did you start on this Ramsey
stuff well going back a couple years
before that
um 2015 uh she was coming out of a a
very toxic marriage I was coming out of
prison
um did a couple years in Indiana for a
drug addiction related stuff
um so we were both kind of starting over
we'd known each other since high school
but we kind of off and on stayed
connected so kind of came back together
and um after we got married in 2016
um we didn't really know what to do we
were living with family
talking to Bankers talking to people
that knew their stuff everybody was
telling us buy a house do this got to
build your credit get credit cards so
that's what we did they never said 17
credit cards was too many they just said
get credit cards I never gave me a
number exactly they never said stop they
just said to do it so we did and we did
it a lot and um
so then
um 2019 we had bought a house we we
really should have been able to afford
it but we were so swamped in every other
area that we ended up selling that moved
back in with family and then we just
found ourselves really really broke and
uh trying to figure out where to go from
there and we found you yeah this new
life was supposed to be fun
it didn't turn out that way so you
bumped into elsewhere
um that would be me um I worked with a
guy for a while uh I wouldn't call his
friends we were just buddies at work
um and I remembered we had an open
enrollment he had mentioned he didn't
need any of the or do any of the
benefits at work he used Zander and I
said what Xander and he said uh the Dave
Ramsey uh stuff and I said what's that
he said the financial guy two and a half
years later uh Tyler Hardesty if you
ever watch this two and a half years
later don't know why it triggered in my
mind but
jump back into it there it was okay so
you just Google it and find us and here
we go just dove in found you yeah yeah
wow congratulations I'm proud of you you
went I trusted Bankers long enough let
me trust this Dave Ramsey guy and see
what he has to say after watching it for
a little while he seemed like he knew
what he was talking about wow so how how
much of a turnaround was it instant or
you just went I'm gonna cut up all 17
cards what was this process like to get
started kick talking and screaming so
was that on your end that was on my part
I was very very reluctant I had been in
a toxic marriage and I said you know
from that point forward I'm going to be
independently broke I am not going to be
codependent on anyone else for financial
anything so you said this was a control
thing you're like No One's Gonna tell me
how I'm gonna live my financial life yep
um and you know I thought this is just a
fad he's going to lose interest in this
and then he introduced us to our ELP
Tracy hi Tracy
um who's been our biggest supporter um
keeping us on track but uh show that
very first meeting she'll tell you I was
like I don't want to do this I am not
excited about this this is not how I
wanted to live my life
um but here we are we never said a good
attitude was required okay
that's amazing but you started doing
this Stephanie oh my gosh this actually
works at what point did you flip from
being heels dug into running forward so
there or two I actually started getting
really into the Ken Coleman show and had
some questions about my career he gave
me some really great advice put myself
in proximity of the people who could
make things happen got two promotions
within six months but really I would say
what solidified it for me is I don't
know if you remember but we very
publicly had a hiccup in our financial
peace journey in February so about nine
days before my son was born I went out
and bought a van yep that's us
he called in February and gave his side
of the story and I think you asked if I
lost my dad go mine
I remember
and then I wrote an email the next day
which I didn't expect to get a response
but you
um responded and I think you called him
a twerp
um but uh I think George called us both
grown children he did he did it's all
coming back I don't remember this but
your legendary apparently oh wow a
warranted a response yeah it's funny
that you talk about the YouTube comments
because they were not friendly at all
but um for that for me that was the
changing point you had said there was
some fear there you had said that we
needed to recommit to our why you even
suggested him coming off the road and so
we sat down we had a meeting and we said
this is our why this is what we want to
do and we're going to do it and we
actually I think it was May 2023 was our
projected date and we hit it this
November wow what turned them around
they're going to the Ramsey Woodshed
they get beat up by You Me and the
YouTubers the YouTube comments they get
just destroyed and they go okay okay
it was well deserved who knew that could
be inspiring wow we still have
still out of the way it's right out
there and it's paid off that's awesome
so yeah so what's better to you guys
well done very cool May 2023 but you did
it months and months earlier what
happened
I I think it's fair to say before the
van which was just kind of a catalyst
for us communicating even deeper we were
most well not most but sort of Davis
there was there were some things we
should have cut out of the budget and
things we could have done a little more
intensely and after that it it just the
intensity you just leaned into it when
you realized all the nonsense completely
out of the budget we went a couple
months uh no plastic at all all cash all
envelopes you get called out on National
radio it'll do that
he can't hear me right because once we
gave up the restaurant budget
um that's when things like really like
knocked us out of the park
um was was not eating out eating at home
is cheaper Dave George one more time
there it is oh my gosh you guys are
amazing I'm so proud of you thank you
Don I'm sorry we took you to the
Woodshed but I'm glad it worked out I'm
glad it worked out we did it in love we
love you we wanted you to win and we're
glad you're winning that's awesome it
was it was a good needed motor
Innovation at the time wow
oh my gosh what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is now that
you've done it everybody says the budget
because you have to look at your numbers
if if you're not you just you don't know
what you're looking at or what you're
talking about
um so that is a have to being on the
same page communication I know she would
say having Grace it is it is and that's
part of why we're here is because you
know we had a hiccup we had a really big
setback I bought a van when we were 5
000 from paying off the car that we had
um and so having Grace and understanding
that you're gonna mess up or you're
gonna make mistakes throughout the
journey but it's not a reason to quit
wow that's good I like it good for y'all
well done well done hey we've got a copy
of the the uh live and give box for you
the bundle and that includes The Total
Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
you those things yourself or give them
away to other people enjoy them and
we're so honored to have you here I'm
glad that we get to hear the other side
of a Woodshed story it's the where are
they now that's what's up I have no
recollection of this because I've done
that stuff so many times in 30 years but
I'm so happy 5 000 calls since then so
happy well I mean I'm I'm dude I'm just
I can't remember my name but anyway well
done y'all very very proud of you good
work and you brought the kiddos what are
their names and ages uh this is Walker
he's nine months and Wyatt is 29. all
right cool all right 120 000 paid off in
22 months making 110 to 150 plus or
minus a van count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh wonderful
well done
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
personality
[Applause]
is my co-host open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Tiana is with us in Evansville Indiana
hi Tiana how are you
hi Dave I'm well how are you better than
we deserve what's up in your world
we can afford to move up in house and
whether or not I should allow my mom to
move in as well
okay
um
so what is your payment now
well our house payment is
458. that's pretty cheap what's your
take-home pay
okay all right
and do you have other debts
you do we have
it okay
and so your car payment's bigger than
your house payment
yeah uh no actually it's 280. oh okay
okay all right and what's your household
income now you said 6600 your take-home
pay so your household income is 100
grand
uh
um
80 to 85k but I receive SSI from my
daughters and that that's a fixed income
so
that's how much I get with no tax I see
okay all right
and um so uh well we tell folks not to
have a house payment that's more than a
fourth of their take-home pay on a
15-year fixed
um so you have an awesomely low house
payment
um so you're just wanting a better house
why are you wanting to move
well our neighborhood is a bit sketchy
it always has been but we had a plan to
pay off our house very early that's kind
of why we moved in in the first place
however it got pretty dangerous
um when a month ago someone across the
street from us got shot at and so I
don't I no longer feel safe in the
neighborhood and on top of that um with
my two disabled daughters one of them
has a lot of equipment that requires a
ton of room for her to
um be able to have it with her so we're
we just feel like we need a bigger space
all of that was there when you moved in
though right except for the shooting
part
um
okay so what could you sell the house
for
maybe 80 81. what do you owe on it
70. okay so you could barely get out
right okay so you get out and then you
move and your house payments no more
than a fourth of your take-home pay as
long as you do that that's going to be
okay the trick is you you don't want to
get in a habit of and it doesn't sound
like you are that every time I want to
get a bigger or every time my income
goes up I go get a bigger house because
that just means you stay in debt the
rest of your life so we want to avoid
that but if you make this one move to
get away from the shooting gallery and
and to get a little more room for the
you know for the equipment and
everything then uh that doesn't sound
out of line and why do you want your mom
to live with you
well with my daughters one has multiple
appointments a week that I can't really
make now that my other daughter is
basically homebound
um and I have to be with her literally
24 7. I I can't even walk outside
without having at least another person
with me in case of emergencies
so there's only two people who I am
having trained in her care which is my
husband and my mom and my husband works
very long hours during the day so it
would be just a huge help if she was
there to help take care of my daughters
with me
okay and well your mom doesn't own
anything she's just going to move into
your house and help you with care
um the only downside is is that someday
you know the situation is going to
change and you're gonna you know
there'll be some undoing of that as long
as you don't say this is forever and
ever until you know I'm obligated to do
this for the rest of my life no I mean
we're this is what we're doing for this
season
right okay yeah I mean I that sounds
like a wonderful thing your mom's able
and willing to do that and it sounds
like you've got a pretty strenuous
situation kiddo
um the caveat I'm seeing here is if you
sell this house and you've got zero
dollars you might need to pause and save
up to have something down on the next
house and maybe pay off this car and you
know kind of solve that situation so I'm
wondering could you rent somewhere you
have a good income with 6600 could you
rent for a little while maybe Foundation
yeah a year or two and clean up the car
debt and then build up a good down
payment you're right because you're not
gonna have a down payment that would
give me a little more financial peace
stepping into this situation yeah I
think that's probably a good that's
probably a wise suggestion right there
something to follow Austin's with us
Austin is in Wisconsin hey Austin
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey fellas how are you guys doing today
great how can we help
Hey so uh I'm a 28 year old guy in
college and I just got home from the
jewelry store purchasing an engagement
ring for hopefully my future fiance yay
way to go
yeah thank you guys very much so uh
obviously like I'm a huge fan of the
baby steps and everything and you know
follow them to achieve however when
talking with her about it she has one
asterisk that she wants to make and I
want to know if this is something I
should you know raise us think about
or if this is kind of something I should
just let fall by the wayside and that is
uh so we're both in baby step two right
now
um paying my way through school and
everything and uh my question is should
we put 20 into retirement once we get to
babysit four that's her asterisk or
should I fight about it and make sure
that it's 15 because I really want to
pay off the house as soon as we can but
she's you know looking at the numbers
and thinking that we're going to lose
out a lot of you know like growth and
growth and growth and time and
everything like that yeah so what is her
net worth
so her net worth right now is probably
upwards of 50 000. mine's not
I I completely agree
that's a trick question Dave
if she was so concerned about the power
of compound interest why would she go
into debt in the first place
yeah I'd say there's a fantastic
question so that's a smart alec answer
Austin to say
um you know if you use your best ideas
and your best ideas have gotten you
nowhere you probably should use someone
else's best ideas
I that that's kind of my opinion as well
yeah and that's that's not a 20 versus
15 thing that's not a caveat or an
Asterix thing that's a philosophy of
Life thing
and so it's kind of like saying um you
know I just hired a personal trainer
he has an eight pack and I have a keg
and um I'm gonna do everything he says
but this one thing
well you can do that you can do that but
please don't be arrogant enough to say
it's because you're smarter than the guy
with the eight pack when you have a keg
and then don't blame him when you don't
have the eight pack because you didn't
follow the plan he set out exactly
because I mean he's he's got he's got
the plan to get you to where he is and
he's got proof standing in front of you
that it works now you can adjust his
plan if you want but it's to your own
peril
and tens of millions literally tens of
millions of people have followed these
baby steps so it really honestly it
doesn't matter the 10 versus 20 and all
that doesn't matter what matters is this
idea that
um
that
I'm going to question my personal
trainer who's got a track record you
know that that that's that's the
important part of the question it's not
the this uh the Nuance of you know it
did God ordain fifth no he didn't uh
that's not the point and uh it's just
that the stuff we teach works and so why
would you screw with it that's the thing
broke don't fix it yeah but you know
let's enjoy being engaged and having a
lot of fun and planning a marriage and
uh let's learn to take advice from
people who are ahead of us on the
journey whichever Journey that is
whether it's parenting or marriage or
career or money
that puts us out with the Ramsey Show in
the books
[Music]
Ramsay show videos going viral check out
your favorite moments from the Ramsay
show on YouTube go watch And subscribe
to the Ramsay show channel on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studio it's the Ramsey show where that
is Dome cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for joining us
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Angela Is With Us in Jacksonville
Florida hi Angela welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hello thank you
thank you how can we help
yes sir about three years ago my husband
and I we purchased um a 2019 triple wide
manufactured home and with you know the
hey yeah and with the you know cost of
living and everything else Rising we
just found out that to replace our same
model it's a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars more than we can get insured for
and you know we've called around we've
gotten additional quotes that will go up
to about 190 but still nothing that
would you know offset the cost if we had
a you know a total loss and we're kind
of confused on how we should move
forward because we are
you you are what
we are pretty much debt free that's good
well
um you're going to have a total loss on
this
over the next 10 years 15 years it's
going to become more zero
they go down in value
um
so
uh
you've gotta you've got some I I would
sell it today so while you can get some
money out of it before it goes down in
value more every year you wait it's
going to go down in value not up in
value
the home you own should go up in value
triple wide's double odds do not go up
in value
yes
the um the hardest part about that is we
do I am on family land which is mine
it's deeded to us and I could sell it
but then we would have somebody know you
know right beside us I do have another
acre
where we were kind of you know
we're torn
financially we want to make the best
decision for us because like I said you
know we are almost completely debt-free
we only have twelve thousand dollar
vehicle payment and we'll be completely
debt free
yeah
well here's the thing what would it sell
for today
315 000 that counts the ground
right what's the dirt on Earth
um
75
probably worth what
about 75 75 000.
okay so you you think that the trailer
itself
has a value of
200 000 bucks
yes sir okay
all right
um and so here's the thing
10 years from now the two hundred
thousand dollars is going to be twenty
thousand
or forty thousand agreed yes sir okay
that tells me I have to do something
I don't know what it is exactly we're
going to do but I'm not going to ride
that cam I'm not going to ride the horse
till it dies the horse is sick yes sir
and so
um it could be that I sell it without
the land under it and move it somewhere
or I buy a little piece of land
somewhere move it to that land and sell
that package somewhere uh and get it off
the family land and then build a house
on the family land eventually
um it may be it may be that this process
takes a year or two
um but the insurance problem is just
highlighting the asset depreciating
losing values problem
it's it's telling you you can't do this
it's telling you shouldn't keep it
right so you know if the family land uh
who's uh on the rest of the land
your brother
okay my mother oh your mother I see okay
okay and what's your household income
um about 115 000
very good okay well it might take a
little time to execute but one option
would be
to buy a piece of property somewhere to
move this to move it there get the
septic in get it hooked up have a you
know a full property there with land and
trailer and sell the whole thing you're
probably going to get a lot more for the
trailer if you do that than if you just
sell it with no dirt under it
agreed correct yes that would be my
guess anyway I feel with these things
over the years a few times in the real
estate business but I'm not an expert on
them but I think you can and here's the
thing it's very tempting because you're
dead free to just sit there
but we have to say out loud over and
over again that you're getting ready to
lose a lot of money when you do that
over a decade over a period of time and
I would rather you make a shift here now
that's painful and very very
inconvenient
um and you know end up building a nice
home on there and even if you took on
some a mortgage and you turn and get the
mortgage paid off that kind of thing but
just riding this thing all the way down
it doesn't make sense yeah I'm wondering
if there's an option where they hang on
to the family land but they go moving to
a neighborhood and get a normal house
that will appreciate and value until you
get the well but you can't hang on to
the land you can't leave the trailer
there you got to sell it yeah and if you
sell it you're going to sell the
property next door to your mama which is
that's hard to do I mean it's very hard
to do that's even more inconvenient than
my idea because it's inconvenient
family-wise and sounds like they would
prefer to live there next to her mother
you know and so forth so yeah um
uh so I I just want to see him build I'm
not gonna it's not a panic
but two years from now I'm not gonna be
sitting in the same exact place watching
this thing go down in value
because your net worth is going the
wrong direction
and um and and just because you don't
want to face the inconvenience of of
somehow getting rid of this trailer yeah
uh and it is going to be very it's going
to be a pain in the butt and paid for
Real Estate is a big part of the
Building Wealth yeah and not paid for
trailers no because that's backsliding
yeah it's just a large car financially
it's a large car you sleep in yeah I
mean they go down in value it's that
simple well there's a reason the
insurance company's not messing with it
exactly
they're not going to cover it Jacob is
in Albuquerque New Mexico hey Jacob how
are you
hey doing pretty good
um my question is me and my wife were
having our first child
and I want to start a new business we
both agreed on an action plan but uh I
kind of wanted to go over the
particulars with you and find out you
know if I might be missing something
okay cool I'll tell you what we are
heading into a commercial break it
sounds like a really important question
I'd like to get the details and give you
a proper answer instead of trying to do
it in 24 seconds and so if you'll hang
with me we'll come back to you Jacob and
George and I will walk through this with
you my brother this is the Dave Ramsey
art the Ramsey show where did that come
from
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you've gone through Financial Peace
University our chances are it's because
someone in your life a little fire under
you Mom and Dad gave it to you your
pastor offered it at your church a
friend wouldn't stop talking about it so
you finally took the class then when you
started working the baby steps they
worked and everything's different you
changed your entire future
well now you can light a fire under
someone else you can give someone you
care about Financial Peace University
and share the same hope you've
discovered with money and with Christmas
coming this is the perfect time to do it
and when you give FPU as a gift they get
more and more and more uh it's it's more
than just the course you're going to get
the premium version of every dollar
you're going to get a group call with
our coaching team uh all of this this
Christmas give the people that you care
about a gift that actually matters it's
called hope it's freedom by Financial
Peace University is a gift go to
ramseysolutions.com give FPU
g-i-v-e-f-p-u
Jacob is with us in Albuquerque New
Mexico hi Jacob welcome to the Ramsay
show
hello hello we were talking about you
guys and you're thinking about starting
a business
uh while you got a baby on the way so
what do you do for a living now
uh right now I'm in Pest Control
okay what do you make
I make a 35 500 a year okay
and your wife work outside the home
yes she's a teacher and what does she
make
she makes fifty one thousand nine
hundred okay
and uh what kind of business are you
thinking of starting
a pest control business
okay which would put you in direct
competition with your current employer
so you cannot do it while you're
currently working for them right right
yes sir
how old are you
I'm 36. how long you've been doing Pest
Control
for four years
hmm
when's the baby due
in seven months
yeah
but uh so just a little bit of what's
been going on what we're looking at
numbers wise
um
you know we only owe on the house and uh
we've got
7 900 in the bank right now and with our
bills and everything by the of you know
random numbers for seven months
um I'm thinking we could have anywhere
from 30 to 31 500
set aside
so that's kind of
the reason I was feeling set aside
um by the time the baby gets here so
when are you talking about starting the
business
well uh probably like uh you know within
the next year within the next 12 months
okay so like five or six months after
baby comes
yes sir
okay well that makes more sense than now
great
I wouldn't do it now
um
okay I I love the idea of people being
in business for themselves that want to
be
I I believe in small business I believe
in self-employment I love the idea I
like your hustle I like your I like your
mentality
um what we normally would tell people to
do you don't have this option is to
start your business as a side gig and
grow it until it gets almost as big as
your main gig and then when you walk out
the door you don't feel it
but what you're doing is you're just
jumping out of the airplane and sure
hoping the shoot deploys
messy you know you got you're going from
uh 35 000 to zero
right
yeah because you really can't with good
ethics work on getting customers while
you're
working for somebody in the same
business right
right have you looked into the startup
costs of a pest control business
uh yeah yeah it has what is it what does
the cost look like
well I mean it's really not
I mean it's not very expensive it's
under ten thousand dollars because all
you need is equipment and
um
you know the licensing and things like
that and you'll need money for marketing
a website you're gonna hire people
uh no like At first I would work by
myself
um where are you gonna get your
customers marketing
oh I was thinking either
um like a Google search business
um profile or
um you know radio advertisement
which will cost you money so that's
another thing to factor into the
equation uh there's pest control
companies that have been around a lot
longer with more money with more
marketing with more Google history that
will show up way before you do and so I
would have a a really strong plan of
attack that doesn't involve trying to
sink a whole bunch of money into
marketing
up front right yeah well also too I mean
I'd be hitting the pavement you know
um door-to-door
going to businesses yeah going to you
know hit neighborhoods and kind of
making sales that way too
okay
why would I use you versus ABC that's
been open for 10 years
because I have the experience and I'm
going to show the dedication that ABC
wouldn't show because they're they're
just hiring somebody that's working for
minimum wage that's just going to go in
and spray real quick not even doing
inspection I'm going to come in and do
an inspection every single time okay
what what I just asked you is called
your brand differentiator
how is your brand different from your
competitors and you gave a really good
answer by the way
so you need to get that you need to get
that narrative down because that's why
that's what people are going to be
asking themselves is
um you know why are you different why
would I care I've got someone that
sprays my building now why would I
change
I mean you're going to find a few places
that have zero pest control but not many
most of them you're going to be asking
them to change companies
not start from zero which is good news
because they're already spending the
money
uh they're used to spending the money
you're not trying to get them to spend
more money than they're spending now but
you are getting them to change and
change people don't do unless they got a
reason
right
so yeah I I think you need a big uh War
chest here
and I'm going to send you a copy of our
book entree leadership which is how we
run business here we've got a whole
brand called entree leadership works for
small businesses we work with a lot of
pest control people around the nation as
a matter of fact uh they come to our
entree leadership conferences I've met a
bunch of them over the years and so it
is a good business to be in it's a good
service you provide
there's a lot of different ways to do it
and a lot of things you can do that uh
brand differentiate I endorse one in one
city that uses all natural oh yeah
chemicals I hung out with one in San
Antonio long-time Advertiser have been
with me for 15 plus years we've been
endorsing them there so uh it's a great
great idea great brand differentiator
you know all natural chemicals but I do
my homework and go what are all the
competitors in the air what are they
doing how are they marketing themselves
how can I stand out in the crowd once
the pricing structures look like all of
that you really really really need to do
your detail the good news is you got a
year to get all that ready before you
have to make the jump the the scariest
part of the whole thing Jacob is you're
going to go from you know making money
to zero day one because you really can't
go lay a foundation under the business
in terms of customers or income with
Integrity while you're working for your
yeah you know getting ready to turn your
future thing into a company it may be
wise to jump into a different kind of
sales role where you could start this
Pest Control business on the side take a
different job exactly work in a
completely different field that's going
to give me some Financial Peace if I had
a new you know what if you could do
something else making 35 000
anything for one year while you do this
um and then you're not a competitor and
you can begin to build your Pest Control
business a little bit on the side that's
a great idea George that excites me it
just makes me less nervous for him you
know that's that was a new baby that's
as smart as like Ken Coleman wow good
good income
really really good idea that's cool I
like that that's the way you do it Jacob
because the biggest thing that's
bothering me about this is the zero you
know 35 to zero a lot of risk I think
anyone with a brand new baby some
recipes Sharon would not allow that it's
a recipe for stress
actually she would but yeah you did it
yeah I've done it yeah so there you go
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt-free stage John and Valerie are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you Dave good to see you good to see
you welcome where do you all live
Lancaster Pennsylvania Lancaster I love
it love it love it welcome to Nashville
how much debt have you paid off uh 223
000 in just under four years good for
you and your range of income during
those four years
um it started off with about 70
000 and that was with two incomes and
then it went to a hundred and twelve
thousand on one income wow nice jump
what do you do for a living so I am a
stay-at-home mom and John is a realtor
ah okay and real estate business has
been better than the old job yes it
definitely was so it's funny Dave
actually
um I lost my W-2 job nine to five job um
in 2000 I almost said 2009. in 2019
February of 2019 we were basically both
making thirty five thousand forty
thousand a year there
um scrambled to figure out the next
thing got into real estate that summer
um you know tried to basically it was
beans and rice for a few months until I
started making money in real estate from
when I lost my job in February to the
next June I think I made about fifteen
thousand dollars in real estate so it
was Slim Pickens there for a little bit
yeah but uh she and then finally you
know we were able to finally when our
daughter was born our second child she
was able to stay home she wanted to kind
of make ends meet for a while by then
you had gotten it moving yeah that's
right good what kind of debt was the 223
000. all the stupid everything
um mostly John's thank you obviously
once we got married I took it on too but
those bus tracks right there I see them
yeah yeah
um
student loan car yep and then the house
the house paint off your house yes we
did all right
I love it so what's the house worth uh
probably now a house worth about 275 but
we bought it was worth uh we bought it
for 165. so we owed about 150 on the
time so actually
um the man to your right needs a raise
so I actually thank you John Met George
um last August I I have a podcast for
realtors and I was at a conference in
Nashville called podcast movement ran
into George he was super kind like
everyone that you employ super awesome
talk to me for a little bit said oh I
have family in York I love Lancaster um
and he I said can you record a quick
video to send home to my wife it was
hilarious he basically said we wish you
were here instead of him which is true
um she's the better half and then he
kind of said you know talked about his
and Whitney's journey and said I think
you guys will pay off your house uh even
faster than you think it was our goal
was kind of by the time I was 35 and uh
we did it uh yeah so August I met him
and by June it was paid off so wow so
the man needs a raise Dave I'm just
saying I didn't know I had that kind of
power
so not only amazing he's a prophet he's
got you on board and sped up this whole
process I manifested it yeah and we were
on board so really like we got involved
from a through a church our church at
the time four years ago
um I was not feeling it at first and
then when I wanted to buy a house or buy
something she's like yeah well you look
at these numbers and tell me how we're
going to do that
yeah it was and we were doing a lot Dave
ish yeah at first and then don't do
Davis guys stop yeah stop it took a
little bit to get him on board because I
always grew up with the budget and
everything like that but he didn't and
so we learned a lot through our five
years of marriage and
um so then once he got on he was like he
got on like he was listening to the
podcast and everything every day at work
and everything I needed a life really
yeah she did he was a little obsessed
well congratulations guys how old are
you now
yes sir house and everything you're
officially weird people way to go thank
you congratulations what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
I think you need you need someone that's
going to encourage and Mentor you and
you need to be on the same page I'll
give a shout out to a buddy uh Vincent
puglisi of mine he runs a mastermind
that I'm in every week I learn how to
grow in my business grow as a you know
person of Faith Family through that
mentorship and really I think being on
the same page like we you know I think
the biggest thing that we've kind of
learned is you know in in the class and
we've we've led the class A couple times
you know Rachel comes on and talks about
how oh I'm I'm the spender Winston's the
saver et cetera and so I think like
having people that are like oh no we
don't all like save all our money we
want to spend money we want to go to
Chick-fil-A we want to go to Target it
helps people I mean I think like I I
needed that you know freedom to spend
some money and she was willing to say
okay I think at first you wanted
spending money to be like 50 a month and
I thought like 50 a week or like a day
so it's a balance of it too so wow yeah
way to go guys very very very well done
excellent excellent job all right now
you're teaching the class what do you
tell people the key to be getting out of
debt is
um budget for one follow it to a t which
can be very hard but don't give up
just keep plugging along if you mess up
then it's okay great great yep there's
another day and you can just keep going
I think the coolest thing too Dave is so
I sell real estate in Lancaster right
like I meet clients and
um they we've been open and honest about
our journey the entire time I mean we
didn't say we're broken so I mean June
of 2020 I thought we were going to lose
our house I had barely sold any any real
estate we asked family if we could move
in with them it wasn't a great situation
for them at the time so and from there
like we were like well then we got to do
something about it kind of like when
like you know we're passionate about you
know getting out of debt um figuring
this out we thought we'd have to sell
our house and then literally 24 months
later in June of 2022 the house was paid
off and so I would just encourage you I
mean we were living off forty thousand
dollars for a while so I think so many
people listen to the show and are oh
those people are rich no that's not true
you just gotta get on the plan maybe you
do make forty thousand dollars okay so
what can you cut in your budget
um to make it work and by the way I love
iPhones you guys don't need a new iPhone
every six months I'll just go ahead and
say that that hurt but
spoken like a true iPhone I think you
can fill in for us if we're out yeah I
love this guy got the podcast down I
remember his passion from when we met at
the podcast movement and I'm so proud of
you guys to see you here today less than
a year later having done the hard work
yeah and went full intensity not Dave
ish but all in it's a game changer and
and I think George even I mean people
say all the time on the Facebook Channel
like how you'll respond to Instagram
messages yours are I mean I know you're
busy but I think like even you being
willing to do it I met a great person on
your staff Jeremy earlier when we were
out in the lobby people on your staff
coming down and meeting people people I
mean if you guys like what you see from
Dave what you see from Georgia on the
show is like real life I've met him
um and I think like I think that really
says a lot about your organization and
the people that you hire I have told her
here I apologize to my in-laws but it'll
be when the kids are adults that I want
to come work here when all the babies
are grown up come be part of this
life-changing stuff you guys teach
that's very cool well we would love to
have you here you're you're our kind of
folks obviously way to go George thank
you
you're incredible huh you never know who
you're going to meet I think we are
going to give you a raise instead of one
beaver pelt I'm going to give you two
yeah
yes I needed a matching one this is
perfect
well you guys are an inspiration call
back from an earlier hour okay thank you
so much well done you guys very well
done hey we've got a copy of Total Money
Makeover for you in the live and give
bundle along with the uh the baby steps
millionaires book whatever that book's
called and the uh Financial Peace
University membership you'll be able to
give that to somebody obviously your
leading classes you'll find a deserving
person that needs that so very very well
done we're proud of you guys thank you
so much great work all right bring the
kiddos up let's introduce some names and
ages so this is Kaden he's three and
Liliana is one and a half all right he
was so excited to meet Dave Ramsey and
George George Hill
George Campbell George camel Jordan
[Music]
Dave Ramsey all right I love it all
right John and Valerie Caden and Liliana
from Lancaster Pennsylvania about 223
000 house and everything did it in four
years making 70 to 112 counted down
let's hear a debt free
debt free two one we're dead free
free
[Applause]
[Music]
way to go well done well done man what a
cool couple love this who says you need
a house payment not these guys not these
guys 34 years old mic drop this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Philippians 2 4
Let each of you look not only to his own
interests but also to the interests of
others
Booker T Washington said the happiest
people are those who do the most for
others the most miserable are those who
do the least
no question about it you know who the
other happy people are they're the ones
that give generous people it's very
difficult to find someone who's
outrageously generous who's not also
outrageously happy there's a correlation
have you ever seen anybody that was
depressed that was generous
not that I can think of doesn't come to
mind I always got a big smile on their
face because it's just a lot of fun so
every year we do an annual giving show
we'll be doing it on December 14th in a
couple of weeks if you have a great
giving story or receiving story that
would Inspire others in this whole area
of generosity we need your help we need
to hear your story and America needs to
hear your story and the world needs to
hear your story on this podcast this
YouTube channel and this radio show not
necessarily in that order but there you
go and uh so yeah what do you do email
us at ask
ramseysolutions.com the email address is
ask
ramsesolutions.com put giving in the
subject line put a little bit about your
giving or receiving story and why it's
inspiring team will get back to you and
we will set you up to be a caller to
tell your story on December the 14th on
our special annual giving show
Samantha's in Utah hi Samantha how are
you
I'm great how are you Dave better than
we deserve what's up
our finances and households and
everything like that and
um I'm just looking for some advice as
to how to do that
um I'm in baby step 3B he is well for me
has learned all about your program
um he's enrolled in Financial Peace
University we're taking Financial people
University as of January
um Christmas present and he um he has
some debt I obviously have parenting off
and had a savings
um our big question is is where to live
his
um his place is um expiring the lease is
expiring I'm on a month to month and
we're trying to figure out do we buy
a special in this market yeah
okay you're in debt
okay you don't buy until you're out of
debt and have your emergency fund
inflation your down payment you knew
that
yeah you're not in debt but we are in
debt when we have a we you're not a we
yet but you'll be a we soon
yeah and
and options they have is also um we make
a pretty good income and it's something
that we can clear up pretty quickly good
but wondering
yeah when when is do we live in a 1200
square foot apartment or do we try to
maybe rent something a little bit bigger
well how many rooms do you need how many
kids you guys have
um I have three he has he has two that
are living at home that come to visit
usually on on you know during visit
times okay who's living in a 1200 square
foot
I am with three kids
yep okay and that's the month to month
and his lease is expiring and will not
renew
I he can renew it it's just to be locked
in for another year and um it's more
expensive than mine
okay what's your take-home pay going to
be once you're married
about 450 years a year whoa that's good
news sweet yeah I would go I would go
rent something else for six months
that's nice
and that you guys can get settled into
and begin to get the um The Kinks worked
out of the comp the combining of the
households you will make a better house
purchase decision after you have lived
together a while and been married a
while then you will from just being
engaged
you'll probably buy a different house
you'll probably buy a different house
six months after marriage than you would
buy before marriage
absolutely true
we were looking
to sort of be able to combine everything
together we're going to jump from about
1100 a month to about 3 000 a month
you make a half a million dollars a year
so what yeah but I'm a nerd I know but
it's not and then you're not a nerd
you're a cheap nerd
my kind of people we love you we think
you're amazing but yeah you're you're
right and the point is though okay I'm
not I'm not signing you up for this for
10 years I'm signing up for six months
okay
and uh make sure it's a six month deal
don't sign a three-year lease I mean
because you're you know get in there get
settled get the kids used to the rhythm
of the other ones visiting on the
weekends all this kind of stuff and the
flow of bedrooms and the the dining
there's a lot of family Dynamic that you
guys are gonna that it's going to affect
your house purchase
and when you actually are living in it
versus just perceiving how you think
it's going to be it is going to be a
little different it has to be I don't
think anyone could look at it from the
outside and know I know I couldn't yeah
yeah
so yeah just give yourself a little
mercy here but yeah I don't think you
have to cram into a 1200 square foot or
because it's cheap and you with your
combined income being so huge oh my gosh
we're talking like 30 Grand at least a
month take-home pay more I mean so you
got plenty of wiggle room there even
paying three grand a month for rent and
again it's just a temporary thing and
then yes go buy you a house by the end
of the year no question the end of 24 or
23 rather not not not 22 but yeah yeah
absolutely Adele is in Billings Montana
hi Adele welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello thank you so much for taking my
call sure a little short on time go
straight to your question yep so my
husband and I are 62 we're totally debt
free we have about one and a half
million saved in various like money
markets a brokerage account you know
with um Edward Jones way to go and then
yeah and we um own a home and it's um
paid off and we have it's about worth
700. okay so my sister has property of
mine in California that she that she and
her husband farm and they want to buy it
for 500 000 but we're not sure if we
should keep the property just to
diversify and have this property that we
get about 6 000 a year for six to twelve
return
I don't know because she's family
I would not buy a piece of Farm property
that gave me a one percent rate of
return
well that's half of your network or a
third of your net worth
okay no I'm not sure so this was
inherited land that's mine
and oh I'm sorry I thought you said you
were going to buy it
no she wants to buy it because they're
the farmers oh you own it you own it for
a half a million
and yes okay she wants to pay me a half
a million or should we keep it that's
what we're wondering should we hang on
to the line for the revenue it's
generating because it's only generating
six to twelve years it's not much yeah
it's not much why would you know okay
fine right quick what would be the
reason you would keep it
I have no I I don't know if it's just
smart to keep something besides money in
the bank no
you can put a half a million dollars in
a lot of different things that does
better and that is Money in the Bank
that that you can train one thing
I think I I think the the only reason I
would keep this property if I were you
would be just that it means a lot to me
emotionally because it's an old family
farm but it's staying in the family if
you sell it to her right right right
it is five years from now how much are
you going to hate yourself for selling
this property any at all
none sell it unless
you can buy property that will go up in
value faster than that
I'm not sure it's I'm not sure it's
great investment property I'm not
positive it's not but I'm not sure it is
I think you can make other real estate
investments in Montana for instance and
even investing that that would take 500
into that brokerage account it could
generate way more than six or twelve a
year I'd bring a half million to
Billings and invest it around there in
real estate if you want to own some real
estate for investment purposes but if it
if you had a half million dollars
sitting on the counter and you didn't
own this you wouldn't go buy it
that tells you not to keep it that tells
you not to keep it right there that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
all of our shows with the Ramsay Network
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]